séné comme une légende la plus grande de
tout nous avons cassé durant milan pour
protéger la terre du sort qui lui
étaient destinées optimus prime tu as
détruit et au monde tu cherches la
rétention
wima créatrice je la cherche
[Musique]
à ta fille qu'est ce que tu lui dirai
aussi toile et dans fais tes devoirs
traîne pas avec un maquis et dans un
groupe surtout le batteur
nous vivons des heures sombres 110
d'heure le chaos s'installe
de monde entrent en collision
et vous êtes notre dernier espoir
désormais la plus grande émission
changer le sorte d'humanité
tél
c'est pas ça
la destruction de tout ce que nous
connaissons les que nous aimons a
commencé
je partirai pas sans toi
semble perdu quelques âmes courageuses
peuvent sauver tout ce qui nous est cher
l'opération est terminée on lâche pas
optimus enquête
je veux rester
et moi aussi je veux me battre
[Musique]
pour que mon monde survivent
le vôtre doit à mourir
[Musique]